gun ownership goes up crime goes down
universally everywhere it is how it
works F Kennedy for recent TV I'm here
with Emily Miller she's a senior editor
and columnist with the Washington Times
she's done a long series about getting a
gun and the laws in the District of
Columbia and beyond so why did you want
a gun in the first place
well it hurts me finally because I was a
victim of a home invasion and then I
started looking into it and it was so
hard to get a gun and then I thought you
know what this is crazy like why is it
so hard to get it gone I'm Washington DC
with very restrictive gun laws most
objective in the country Wow yeah it
takes 17 steps to get a gun in DC
including cost four hundred sixty-five
dollars in fees I mean that's not even
including the cost of the gun and I you
know I started this series I thought
it's gonna take a couple weeks she's
gonna be a hassle for a couple weeks
I'll waiting a lot of lines I had no
idea to the most more DMV you have to go
through the DMV to get it done twice I
mean they make it so restrictive so
people don't know me yes I mean that's
the whole purpose of what DC has done in
the Supreme Court in 2008 overturned
their gun bans so they they had to let
it go but in order to really stop people
from getting guns let me clarify in
order to stop the law-abiding people
from getting guns the bad guys they've
got thousands of rounds that help
because DC has very low gun violence
right I mean there's a direct
correlation between no one having guns
and there being no gun violence so it's
really worked out well this whole system
in fact the violent crime has doubled in
DC so far this year and violent crime
and this is what violent crime has
become in DC they're stealing our
iPhones with guns so now are more women
buying guns yeah women gun ownership as
at its highest ever in history forty
three percent of women have guns in the
home
Wow it's become like this amazingly
great trend I think for women to defend
themselves and it's also a fun sport so
for both reasons and you know I get all
those coupons like LivingSocial and
Groupon and every couple weeks there's
one for women shooting packages at
ranges so I think it's become you know
sort of a cool thing to do how did you
decide what kind of gun to get um I
heard that it was the same gun that the
seals used to kill Osama bin Laden and I
thought that's pretty badass that I
wanted to be badass I thought that was
cool and let's do some shooting
absolutely all right yeah yeah
this is not girl [ __ ] this is good shoe
thanks Emily that was awesome
and thanks so much to sharpshooters here
in Lorton Virginia Mike Collins and
everyone has been amazing and they
taught us so much for a reason to be